- [Gary] Sittin' here
listening to my music list
and I'm starting to
find a little clarity.
Starting to understand
why this thing is so hard.
This game of entrepreneurship.
Shit, this game of life.
It's because the real
answer is really found
when you're pulling
from opposite directions.
I'm sitting here
laying and saying
why? Why? Why am I so blessed?
Why is all this
good stuff happening?
And it's because
I'm a contradiction.
Because I've got
this funny juxtaposition
where I'm pulling
from opposite directions.
I don't give a fuck what
any of you think about me
yet I'll read every comment and
I'll listen to everything
all of you say about me
'cause I listen.
I talk a fuck load.
I'm always talking.
I'm cutting
people off, I'm talking.
But I'm listening,
I'm listening 24/7.
I'm always patient.
I'm playing the long game.
But I'm always
quitting things, every day.
Trying, testing,
not crippled by
stop and starting.
How do I figure that out?
How do I understand when it's
time to give up on something
or when it's time to persevere?
How do I understand
and how do I feel and
how do I decide when to
listen to somebody's feedback
or to know when they're
trolling and don't give a fuck
or only seeing surface level?
How is this happening?
How am I working 24/7/365
yet it doesn't feel
like I'm working?
How am I always
constantly putting out content
and building my brand
yet never thinking about it
and just living my life?
How am I documenting
instead of creating?
Where is this?
Where is this zen coming from?
Where is this call
to action coming from?
Why is this plan working so well
and how, how do I
get all you youngsters
(laughs) and
when I say youngsters
I mean the 59-year-old who
hasn't grown up yet,
who hasn't been
willing to look at the world.
And it comes from this,
it comes from the most macro.
It's clearing up for me.
I'm starting to see it.
It's understanding
that nobody gives a fuck
and that that's okay and
that's the way it should be.
I live on empathy.
You shouldn't give a fuck.
You've got you to worry about.
I'm empathetic to that.
That's the game and we're
all dealt with different cards.
We've all got
strengths and weaknesses.
We've got the advantages
and the disadvantages.
Plenty see white privilege,
so do I.
I see privilege in
being from the streets
and having zero
and being hungrier.
There's so many different ways.
And of course, some
are better than others
at the most macro but
I don't even spend the
time to figure that out
because by the
time you figure out
if it was fair,
you're fucking finished.
And so instead
of doing that I do
and I do and I do.
And I'm always
planning and I'm not planning.
And I've always got a
game plan and a strategy
and I've always not got one.
I'm just going off the hip
from intuition,
from learned behavior,
from pattern recognition because
I've been doing
this from the get.
When I was 12,
13, 14, 15 I knew.
I did. It's why I got
those shit grades.
Shout out to everybody that saw
that report card on Instagram.
You know, it's what I do
and so as I sit here
laying, look and think,
and debate and
look out at the ocean
and listen to this music
it's becoming clearer.
2017 could be a great year.
Not just for me but for you
because as I find clarity
I'm gonna suffocate negativity.
I'm gonna suffocate excuses.
If you're gonna
be in my community
you're gonna give up and leave
if you want to
believe in those things
because I'm gonna
pound it, push it, press it
harder than I ever have before.
Because the truth is
I'm thankful. I'm grateful.
I'm working on myself 24/7,
my goals, my ambitions
and I'm working on your
goals and your ambitions 24/7.
That's pulling from
opposite directions.
That's what I do.
That's what I do harder,
stronger, better than anybody.
Honey Empire, bitches.
Building biggest
building of all time.
The biggest, best
business of all time
like a fucking tortoise.
Like a slow fucking tortoise.
Chip away every day.
Underestimated
all along the way.
Got my fans who are delusional,
I got the rest of them,
the majority of the market
that doesn't think I can get it.
That doesn't see the behavior
'cause they're thinking 2017,
they're thinking 2019,
they're thinking 2021.
I'm thinking life, bitches.
I'm thinking
mother fucking life.
And so I promise you community,
the people that are
listening to this right now
you've given me the
greatest fucking gift of all.
You keep your
$500 master classes,
you keep your
$5,000 masterminds,
you keep your $97 e-books.
You keep that in your pocket
and you do you.
You're gifting me with the
greatest fucking thing on Earth.
Your attention and
your word of mouth.
Every fuckin' time
you tag somebody
in my comments on Instagram,
every time you share
my story on Snapchat,
every time you
post and share Facebook
means the world to me.
Every retweet
That means you're putting me on.
You're co-signing
this fucking journey
and for that I will
never take it for granted.
I love you. Happy 2017.